at what point were you told by your
producer that you needed a script
did you already have footage with sierra
yep i already had footage with her
i'd shot some documentary stuff and then
just some raw stuff of us kind of
filming each other
and just exploring where the movie could
go so there was a bit of a general sense
but my producer was just like you have
to write
a script you have to give me a 90 page
script and it was a brutal
process i mean i've written scripts
before but
never for something that is inspired by
reality and that was really tough
like reconciling this documentary
footage and the reality of her world
with a
fictionalized storyline and trying to
keep the fictionalized storyline
authentic feeling and still connected to
the reality
so it was a torturous process i like to
write in shitty motels
oh wow i did a lot of road trips and
would stay in
you know kind of like bates motel level
places i don't know why i can just think
straight when i do that
and you know a lot of riding just
happened walking on the beach
you know very early on i went to jarvis
bay in australia i smoked a joint
and started asking questions why does
anyone want to be ruined
what are people really wanting from
their interaction with her
is she a therapist does she heal people
in some ways these guys seem to be
you know so enamored with her like she's
a goddess or or
you know a healer like people said crazy
things about her you know in terms of
the influence that she had on their life
much beyond getting off but actually had
made them a better person
so just asking all these questions
allowed talking into my iphone recorder
that was how i started finding
okay what are the themes i really want
to explore so
you know it's not just about sitting
there writing on your laptop it's for me
it's a lot of voice recorder stuff
that's kind of how i do a lot of my
processing of ideas
i'm just wondering were a lot of these
men men that were in charge and so it
kind of felt good to reverse roles or
i'm just
assuming that no for sure there is that
and it's such a misnomer when you say a
submissive
male because you meet these guys and
they're high-powered
ceos now that's a bit of a cliche i'm
not saying everyone is like a judge or a
millionaire or something
but my take on human sexuality is it's
very compartmentalized if you have one
of these fetishes
it's because you probably were exposed
to something at a young age and
something just got hardwired in your
brain
to me that doesn't have a lot to do with
who you are in day to day life they can
be
very separate and i really found that a
lot
you know and some people like oh these
guys seem so normal when you meet them
i already had made that cognitive jump i
was like well of course
they're just people they just happen to
get off on this thing that you find
strange
and it's almost a coincidence that they
get off on that you know it doesn't
define
who they are but the film definitely
looks at what happens if you bring a
fantasy into reality
and the dangers of that because
sometimes it's better to keep your
fantasies in a little box
we all want our fantasies to come true i
would say this film explores a little
bit
well what happens if that fantasy comes
into reality what happens if you live
your fantasy
maybe you should be careful what you
wish for
and you went to a lot of conventions
with her or did and you
got to see like meet and greets oh yeah
i met all the women doing this line of
work
amazing people great friends of mine now
oh i got really deep
i got really deep into it i went to the
adult film expo a few times
in las vegas and and uh man
i mean again talk about blurring the
line between fantasy and reality
there's a giant party in the film
and we threw a real mansion party
in las vegas with real porn stars and
people attending and clients and
it was like we were shooting these
scripted scenes in a real
party atmosphere so that was a crazy
experience but again it kind of
reflected in the footage it's got this
gritty
authentic kind of feeling so i was
always trying to tap into that reality
where possible even if it's a scripted
storyline but this
kind of bedrock of reality it's funny
borat
was a great inspiration for me you know
the sacha barrel yes
just the methodology again that's a
comedy completely different tone
but you know using reality as the
foundation for this fictional storyline
that did it very effectively and that
inspired me a lot yeah so you originally
had the name
you excuse me you originally had the
name ruin me
right and then at what point did you
find out there was another film with
that name
you know i would think in 2017 we became
aware that there was an independent
american horror movie called ruin me
and i was in denial for a while i was
like that's okay
there's just going to be two movies
called ruin me no problem
we all love the title ruin me um but
then you get to a point where you're
just like
you know it's not gonna work because
people go to google ruin me and their
film comes up instead of yours or people
start buying the wrong
thing on itunes once it's available so
you know we just spoke to enough
distributors and
and some friends were sales agents or
you know people in marketing and they
were like
you need your own identity have your own
digital footprint don't confuse
yourself in the marketplace so it was
tough but we we made the change
and now i prefer the title use me i
really do because
addiction is quite a central theme in
the movie so
the word use using that concept
that kind of makes sense for this movie
yeah and both parties are using one
another
you know yeah and who's using who right
all that kind of thing sure
so yeah look i mean um i i wanna
i haven't seen the horror movie ruin me
i heard it's quite good and you know i
wish those guys all the best it's just a
shame it i mean i think it was just a
it was just a coincidence it happened
sometimes you both come up with the same
title at the same time they got theirs
out first so we kind of had to say all
right you have it and
we'll change the name any tips for
filmmakers that have
are saying okay i need to change the
name and we're already like picture
locked or whatever
any tips for them boy it's tough i mean
we had a four-page
document
i would just say figure out the essence
of your original title
so we looked at it okay ruin me
you'd think that the word ruin is the
key
aspect of it so we looked at ruined as a
title but it just wasn't as active
then we came to realize that actually
the me was the word
that command do something to me that
sense of a transaction
so we got rid of the word ruin and then
we thought well what else can be done
okay use me yeah you know
mutually using each other and it kind of
begs a question of yeah who is using who
so i guess figure out what the essence
of your title is and there's usually
another way you can express that yeah
and then
how many places did you have to then go
i mean i'm sure on imdb you had to go
and change it and
totally yeah it's a bit of a logistical
nightmare but
better to do it while you're still in
production and the film hasn't been
released than later
you don't want to change it after you've
released it so my advice is if there's
any confusion in the marketplace
better just bite the bullet and and just
change your title
and if it's a good movie i mean titles
are super important don't get me wrong
but if it's a good movie it's still
going to be a good movie no matter what
you call it
sure yeah and you updated your
kickstarter
backers yeah absolutely they were
transparent about the whole process and
and you know they were attached to the
title ruse that ruined me
but now they they love the title used me
so
it's great yeah and were most of these
backers excuse me
i get maybe you answered this previously
but were they fans of sierra
or they were just in that space whether
they were
consumers of that type of material
actually 50 50. you know obviously she's
got
a fan base who are going to follow her
and support
projects that she wants to do creatively
and then people who are into bdsm or
femdom
but at least 50 percent of people who
have no interest in that world
maybe they like films that i've done
before maybe they're just like thrillers
you know we we did manage to tap into an
audience who was
a little bit more mainstream and that
was great that was actually what gave us
a real
shot in the arm and made us think okay
this film hopefully can
can break out a little bit you know we
don't want to just preach the converted
we want to find you know a wide audience
for this film so that was encouraging
you